hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
elon musk he's doing
elon musk stuff who's your biggest enemy
right now yeah who is red who is your
base i don't know
well i i i i did challenge vladimir
putin to uh
one on uh
you know single combat
what like i'm not sure he's my biggest
enemy but he i did challenge him to this
one what does that mean single combat
yeah
dana white dana white
joe rogan
i think it would be an interesting
question because he's like good at
martial odds you guys would have time to
train and [ __ ] too he's pretty buff i
don't know so you see those pictures of
him on a horse and stuff i mean putin i
don't those russians are tough man yeah
what's your skill set i'm not doubting
you but like i'd be i'd be trying to be
like i don't know look at those arms i i
i do have a bit of a weight advantage
but what's your game plan in the octagon
though yeah are you like a ground guy or
like i think you're a striker you got to
use your reach you're a striker maybe
but what would your game plan be against
putin would you take him out now he said
like he has like one judo championships
and stuff so oh she's already just
pretty good going out the right guy
is number two
um but but i i i think i'm probably 50
percent higher than him so
um
i i could um
you know
yeah i mean if you've got a big weight
advantage um
that that can overcome a lot of
technique you know um have you ever
talked about like i i i have a move
called the walrus
what's that which i used on a friend of
mine who's
actually like like she's like very very
agile and and
whatnot but i was like let me explain to
you why there are weight classes in mma
i'm going gonna use a a move called the
wall rust where i just lie on you
and you can't get away
you just like suffocate them you said
you tried that on the wall right
and you're stuck i'm gonna try that on
steiny yeah yeah well that will win
if you have size on him in a way i'm
milan you're putin yeah if you're
pregnant advantage just use them unless
you and gabriel have tried that they're
just kind of you just lie on them and
said that's the whole move you ever been
well you see joe rogan saying that right
now he's got him in the walrus
you ever been in a fight like yeah
what
was the last fight you've been in
um someone talking about there's a bar
fight
no i when i grew up the things were very
violent so i wasn't i mean i never i
never started a flight or anything but i
had a lot of fights i didn't want to be
in
um and i got beaten up really badly in a
few of them actually so
um
but uh so i've been in like real
hardcore street fights really what age
uh
i don't know from when i was
maybe six to
16 ish
well like people picking on you and [ __ ]
or
yeah
um
i grew up in south africa it's a very
violent place
so you think that's what motivated you
to become what you are
i mean maybe played a role certainly
toughen you up that's for sure
i mean the people say like um
you know
they're all worried about words and
stuff people are worried about words
never been punched in the face i'd say
you're punching the face real hard right
on the nose man
you'll take any words rather than that
you know
you